good morning believe nation today's
message is stay on your own path over to
you Kerry Washington I had a yoga
teacher who said to me always stay on
your own yoga mat because sometimes if
you're in headstand and you're too busy
looking at the person on the other mat
you could literally break your neck I
feel like that's a really good metaphor
for life to stay on your own path do
what's right for you
you can't compare your insides with
somebody else's outsides because you
never know what's going on for somebody
else really so I think comparing
yourself to others can be encouraging
but also can be discouraging and it's
important to understand what kind of
feeling you're getting from doing it I
think on the positive side I think
looking at what other people have done
can be a source of inspiration for me
watching the top 10 videos yeah
expressive videos to belief life videos
seeing these great entrepreneurs off
doing amazing things that's encouraging
for me that's inspiring for me that
makes me want to push harder do more not
settle break free from my environment
and go off and you know hit that next
phase that's really encouraging for me
even looking at other youtubers who
might be ahead of me in a different
space a different field you know I might
want to I want to might want to cross
where they're at you know beat their
their subscriber numbers or view numbers
right it's like serves a short-term
motivation that's encouraging for me
the downside is the discouraging part
which can impact a lot of other people
where if you look at a Steve Jobs and
you say listen Steve Jobs is already a
mega success in his 20s I'm 45 and
trying to launch my business I'm never
gonna make it because I'm not in my
twenties I'm not a young kid so I can't
do it or starting something on YouTube
well look at that person they you know
they started off and in six months
already add a hundred thousand
subscribers I'm two years in and I'm
still struggling you know that can be
the negative side of it and so paying
attention to how you see those things in
your environment matters because if
you're looking at somebody else and
that's discouraging for you then stop it
right or just try to pull the
positive out from them you're never
gonna have success being exactly like
Steve Jobs or being exactly like me and
my YouTube channel be exactly like
somebody else right at the end of the
day the message of stay on your own path
is important because you only the only
path for you to have massive success is
to be you and to really embrace the
special uniqueness about you and go
all-in on that to go create something
that nobody else has done before so you
end up creating something new where
you're playing in an environment and
nobody can touch you because you're off
being you and nobody can beat you right
except for you but I think looking at
other people I see a positive side to it
if you can find that that encourages you
to want to do more so depending on your
view is it encouraging or discouraging
to look at other people who've had
success and potentially model them or
potentially be the Scourge by them is
important and for you to understand what
is it that gets you motivated and
excited and full of belief whatever that
is if that's you meditating in the
morning if that's you watching other
videos if that's you having conversation
with people if that's you looking at the
you know feedback from your customers
that's you tapping into you know the
pains that you had in building this
thing up and wanting to see this come
together whatever gets you off on a high
whatever it takes you from this flat you
know emotion to up here like I want to
go do something big
whatever creates that chasm for you that
great leap forward then that's what you
want to inject daily in the morning into
your life so you're off doing something
amazing so the question that today is
I'm curious that's looking at other
people who had a lot of success is that
encouraging for you or discouraging for
you or both let me know I'm curious put
it in the comments below I'm gonna join
in the discussion thank you guys so much
for watching I hope you have an amazing
day I believe in you I hope you continue
to believe in yourself in whatever your
one word is I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot events better
I spray so give me go